en este vídeo vamos a trabajar algunos
ejemplos sobre curvas de valoración así
como todo lo que podemos deducir de
ellas con ayuda del punto medio de
equivalencia aprenderemos a determinar
la curva representa una valoración de un
ácido o una base fuerte o si es un ácido
o una base débil además vamos a ver un
problema sobre el punto de valoración de
un ácido débil y con la información que
nos da vamos a poder concluir bastantes
cosas sobre ese ácido muy bien así que
empecemos justo aquí he dibujado cuatro
curvas de valoración así que vamos a ver
si podemos repasar todo lo que hemos
aprendido para tener una mejor
comprensión de estas cosas así que lo
primero que quiero preguntarte es cuáles
de estas curvas representan la
valoración de un ácido y cuáles de estas
curvas hablan sobre la valoración de una
base y bueno estoy seguro que tú me vas
a decir oye sal pero todo lo que hemos
hecho hasta ahorita ha sido con puros
ácidos
voy a saber cuál es el de una base sin
embargo quiero que sepas que la lógica
que hay detrás para la valoración de una
base es muy similar a la que usamos para
un ácido así que por ejemplo estás aquí
son valoraciones de un ácido ya que
empezamos con ph bajos o bueno recuerda
que esta es la escala del ph déjame
ponerlo p h también lo voy a poner por
eje de h y por aquí
así que en este caso empezamos con un ph
bajo y después de agregar un valorador
un reactivo este ph empieza a aumentar
pero lo importante es fijarnos que su
punto de inicio tiene un ph menor que 7
justo este pasa lo mismo
aquí tenemos un ph bajo y después
aumenta de modo que claramente estos dos
son ácidos y es más déjame de una vez
ponerlo ácido
si no y esto también es un ácido
sí
de lujo ahora estas otras dos el punto
de inicio antes de que comencemos a
valorar esta arriba obtiene un ph muy
alto
aquí está arriba de 7 obtiene un ph muy
alto y por lo tanto puedo decir que
estas dos son valoraciones de bases así
que déjame ponerlo aquí esta va a ser
una base y esta también va a ser una
base y yo sé que hasta ahora no hemos
cubierto bases pero es exactamente la
misma idea en la valoración de un ácido
empiezas con un ácido y le agregas una
base fuerte para que absorba todo el
ácido hasta que llegas a un punto en
donde todo el hidrógeno es absorbido es
decir llegas al punto de equivalencia en
este caso en esta primera gráfica el
punto de equivalencia está justo por
aquí y ahora conforme agregues más y más
base fuerte esto se está haciendo súper
básico de modo que en este ácido este es
mi punto de equivalencia déjame ponerlo
justo por aquí mientras que en este otro
el punto de equivalencia está justo por
aquí aquí tengo mi punto de equivalencia
y si recordamos un poco todo lo que
hemos visto acerca de ácidos fuertes y
ácidos débiles podemos decir de una
manera muy rápida cuál de estos dos es
un ácido fuerte y cuál es un ácido débil
de hecho la de abajo estamos hablando de
un ácido que en su punto de equivalencia
justo aquí llegamos a un momento en
donde se absorbió todo el ácido tenemos
una solución completamente neutra
todo esto se ha convertido en agua en su
estado natural con un ph de 7 de 7 y
bueno seguramente podemos tener algunas
de sus bases con jugadas neutras
sobrantes ahí pero recuerda que dado que
es un ácido fuerte esas bases con
jugadas no hacen nada no agregan nada al
ph es decir realmente no son tan básicas
recuerda por ejemplo el cloruro de
hidrógeno el guión de cloro claramente
no cambia el ph así que este es un ácido
fuerte déjame ponerlo con este color
ha sido fuerte fuerte en este caso
mientras que en este otro caso que está
pasando bueno llegamos al punto de
equivalencia justo aquí en este punto
recuerdan que pasa lo siguiente se ha
acabado todo el hidrógeno y todo el
ácido de disolución llegamos a este
punto de inflexión y ahora después de él
bueno todos los baches que sigamos
agregando aumentan significativamente el
ph pero cuando estamos justo aquí en el
punto de equivalencia el ph ya era
básico tenemos un valor arriba de 7 este
7 tenemos algo arriba de 7 y eso es
porque nuestra base con jugada de este
astro débil va a hacer que la solución
sea más básica así que este de arriba es
un ácido débil de bill y bueno recuerda
que en el caso de ácidos fuimos
aumentando la concentración de hidróxido
así que es importante ponerlo estoy
agregando aquí
h menos justo para esta solución no se
puede ser tu base favorita en mi caso me
gusta mucho
agregar hidróxido de sodio pero bueno
este es un ejemplo estamos agregando una
base fuerte para así valorar estos
ácidos ahora bien en estas situaciones
cuando hablamos de bases bueno lo que
vamos a hacer es empezar con una base y
agregar un ácido fuerte por ejemplo
podemos empezar con cualquier base y
agregar no sé se me ocurre cloruro de
hidrógeno ácido clorhídrico es decir
algo que absorba el o h así que aquí lo
que queremos es absorber el h y hacer
que su concentración baje va a ir
bajando su ph y de repente vamos a
llegar hasta un cierto punto am se me
ocurre ponerlo con este color hasta un
cierto punto justo este de aquí en donde
hemos absorbido todo el h es decir toda
la base se ha ido y justo en este punto
en este caso tenemos un ph neutro eso
quiere decir que cuando absorbimos toda
la base
estamos completa
neutros es decir con un p hd7 y en este
caso estamos diciendo que los ácidos
conjugados realmente no son tan ácidos
no afectan el ph así que este arriba es
una base fuerte podemos concluir que
esta es una base fuerte y bueno aquí voy
a poner que en este caso lo que estamos
haciendo es agregando protones de
hidrógeno estamos agregando protones de
hidrógeno esto para absorber la base en
este caso también vamos a agregar
protones de hidrógeno sin embargo en
esta de abajo sucede lo mismo estamos
absorbiendo toda la base hasta que
llegamos justo aquí a nuestro punto de
equivalencia por aquí tenemos nuestro
punto de inflexión en el cual date
cuenta que en este caso tenemos un ph el
cual es menor que 7 vamos a acabar justo
aquí
justo aquí lo cual por aquí también
pasaba pero en este caso tenemos un ph
por debajo de 7 eso quiere decir que aún
sobra un poco de ese ácido conjugado
incluso después de que vemos
toda la base hace que cambie el pp aquí
así que esta es una base que ya sabemos
que es débil de vid y bueno solamente
para recordar un poco todo lo que hemos
visto acerca de ácidos y bases y de
hecho sobre todo de bases déjame
escribirte para acá algunas reacciones
de base si recuerdas habíamos visto
alguna como la siguiente si yo tengo a
menos
estamos hablando una base que va a estar
en equilibrio va a estar en equilibrio
con lo siguiente con a h ya que agarra
los iones de hidrógeno del lago
circundante recuerda que todo esto está
en una solución acuosa más o h negativos
de modo que después de que agregas ácido
clorhídrico recuerda el ácido
clorhídrico se ve más o menos así este
es un ácido fuerte y este se disocia por
completo en protones de hidrógeno más
uniones de cloro
entonces agregamos ácido clorhídrico a
esta base débil bueno pues estos se van
a absorber con estos estos dos se
absorben así que la concentración de h
va a bajar y mientras más ácido
clorhídrico agreguemos más va a bajar y
bajar y bajar y bajar y conforme
absorbamos o h es de esta reacción date
cuenta que la reacción en equilibrio va
a ir cada vez más hacia este lado hacia
el lado derecho esto por el principio de
leche tellier más y más en más de esta
base débil se va a transformar en este h
y en este o h hasta llegar a un punto en
donde ya no tenemos más de esta base
débil y tenemos un montón de estos a h
es un montón de ellos y mientras
agregamos más y más hidrógenos entonces
esta solución se va a volver cada vez
más y más y más ácida de modo que el
punto de equivalencia es donde ya no
tenemos esta base débil y bueno
solamente cabe decir que justo
punto tenemos mucho más ácido conjugado
en la solución lo cual hace que el punto
de equivalencia sea ya un poco ácido
este es un ph de 7 pero bueno ahora todo
esto lo vemos de una forma general
fíjate bien todo esto está de una forma
general qué te parece si ahora hacemos
un problema donde utilicemos algo de
números porque hasta ahorita no hemos
utilizado casi números así que me voy a
bajar
justo por acá para trabajar un problema
en donde dibujar el justo que un ácido
débil y lo reconocerás justo ahora
porque ya eres muy bueno reconociendo
esto pero en esta ocasión vamos a tratar
con números reales así que vamos a
dibujar por aquí un ph de 7 vamos a
poner justo por aquí mi gráfica y bueno
por aquí tengo un ph de 7 justo la mitad
lo dejaré poniendo así este es mi ph de
7 y bueno me voy a tomar la siguiente
gráfica
imagínate que empezamos por aquí ok y
por lo tanto estamos diciendo que vamos
a valorar un ácido
va a ir subiendo por aquí va a ir
subiendo por aquí es un ácido débil por
aquí se valora justo así aquí tenemos a
mí ha sido débil y de hecho justo aquí
tenemos al punto de equivalencia justo
por aquí y bueno date cuenta que está
arriba del 7 ahora vamos a ponerle un
poco de números a todo esto imagínate
que yo utilizo hidróxido de sodio para
valorar este ácido m
h y me tomo una solución al 0.2 molar ok
pongamos la solución
0.2 molar
además déjame decirte que justo aquí en
el punto de equivalencia si lo bajamos
justo a donde cruza con la cantidad que
utilizamos de hidróxido de sodio nos da
el valor de 700 mililitros 700
mililitros para valorar este ácido así
que la primera pregunta que te tengo es
cuánto ha sido débil teníamos es decir
cuál era su concentración así que lo que
buscamos es la concentración de este
ácido débil que nosotros estamos
valorando y bueno recuerda que aquí
tenemos una a la cual representa
cualquier tipo de ácido ácido débil ok y
ahora mi pregunta va a ser cuál es la
concentración de este ácido débil y
bueno para responder a esa pregunta qué
te parece si empezamos con 3 litros de
ácido débil así que lo voy a poner que
tengo 3 litros y bueno recuerda que
cuando nosotros estamos valorando un
ácido y justo aquí tengo
equivalencia debimos de haber agregado
los suficientes moles de h para llegar a
este punto y así cancelar todos los
moles que tenemos de este hidrógeno es
decir los mismos moles del ácido débil
que tenemos aunque recuerda que la
concentración principal es la de mí ha
sido débil y bueno estos 700 mililitros
de mi reactivo que agregue deben de
tener la misma cantidad de moles que la
cantidad de moles con la que empezamos
con este ácido de estas de acuerdo
obviamente mientras estemos agregando
reactivo estaremos agregando volumen a
esta solución así que mi pregunta sigue
siendo cuántos moles hemos absorbido es
decir cuántos moles de h hay en esta
solución bueno pues es que si tenemos
una solución a 0.2 molar eso significa
que realmente tengo 0.2
hidróxido de sodio por cada litro de mi
solución y si a esto lo multiplicó por
la cantidad de litros que agreguen de
hidróxido de sodio a mi solución lo cual
sabemos que son 700 mililitros que por
cierto si recordemos el punto decimal es
exactamente lo mismo que 0.7 litros
tengo 0.7 litros a una solución de 0.2
muebles por litro eso quiere decir que
si yo multiplico estos dos me va a dar
la cantidad de moles que tenía o dicho
de otra manera la cantidad de moles dna
que agregue a la solución que por cierto
es la misma cantidad de moles que voy a
tener de ohl h
así que si multiplicamos esto me va a
quedar a 2 por 7 es 14 14 y si
recorremos el punto decimal 12 veces me
queda punto 14 mol
moles o dicho de otra manera he agregado
punto 14 moles de nh o también lo puedes
ver como que he agregado punto 14 moles
de h los cuales se tuvieron que haber
cancelado con estos hidrógenos que tengo
aquí por lo tanto ya puedo decir que
empecé con un punto 14 moles de estos
hidrógenos que tengo aquí ahora yo lo
que quiero saber es la concentración de
mí ha sido débil no la cantidad de
muertes que tengo que por cierto ya
sabemos que es 0.14 moles de ácido débil
con lo que empecé pero yo tenía 3 litros
de este ácido débil por lo tanto para
sacar la concentración de ácido débil
habrá que dividir mi cantidad de moles
entre la cantidad de litros así que
ahora sí si lo anotamos la concentración
de este ácido h am que es justo lo que
yo estoy buscando es exactamente igual
que bueno 0.14 déjame ponerlo aquí a
0.14 moles ok
/ bueno la cantidad de litros que tengo
que son 3 / 3 litros así que déjame
ponerlo con este mismo color entre 3
litros ahora habrá que hacer esto pero
antes de eso quiero que te quede muy
claro lo siguiente yo agregué 700
mililitros de nh a una solución de 0.2
molar o dicho otra manera por cada litro
que yo tenía de nh tenía 0.2 moles que
puedes pensar como átomos o moléculas de
o h las cuales las agregue a mi solución
original estos baches se cancelan con
exactamente el mismo número de átomos
que yo tendría de mí ha sido débil es
decir se cancela con cada uno
estos hidrógenos y por lo tanto puedo
afirmar que esta es la misma cantidad
que yo tengo de mi ácido original la
misma cantidad de átomos o de moléculas
con las que empecé y ahora sí sin divido
0.14 moles entre 3 litros que me va a
dar para eso voy a sacar por acá mi
calculadora y vamos a hacerlo punto 14
entre 3
es lo mismo que m
0.0 46 o redondeado 0.0 47 y voy a poner
que esto me quedo 0.0 47 mola ahora
seguramente también te estás preguntando
cuánto vale ni p k
y bueno para resolverse a preguntar lo
único que necesitamos saber es cuál es
el punto medio de equivalencia es muy
fácil recuerdas justo lo vimos en el
vídeo pasado si yo me paro justo a la
mitad 700 mililitros es decir como por
aquí lo cual son 350 mililitros que es
mi punto medio de equivalencia y con eso
me fijo en mi p h en el ph que tiene
entonces con eso voy a encontrar de una
manera muy simple mi pk
imagínate que esté ph me da no sé el
valor de se me ocurra de 3 por lo tanto
en este caso me ph valdría 3
h valdría 3 que por cierto habíamos
dicho que es el mismo valor que toma el
pk por lo tanto aquí después a ver que
me pica a es igual a tres así que aquí
puedo poner 3
es de lujo y de hecho una vez que
tenemos el pk am ya podemos saber de una
manera muy sencilla cuánto vale mi
constante de acidez mi constante de
equilibrio porque recuerda que el pk am
es el menos logaritmo de esa constante
así que está de lugo ya sabemos bastante
esposa sobre este ácido débil y es que
esto es todo lo que quiero contarte por
este vídeo así que todo lo que hemos
visto ha sido mostrar como a partir del
análisis de la culpa de valoración
puedes obtener información importante
sobre un ácido o una base entonces
experimentalmente puedes tomar un ácido
o una base desconocida y al añadir un
ácido o una base fuerte puedes obtener
la curva de valoración y entonces tú
puedes descubrir algunas de sus
propiedades como lo que vimos en este
vídeo encontramos la concentración
inicial de tu ácido o bueno en su dado
caso de tu base
la constante de equilibrio en el caso de
que estés tratando con ácidos o bases
débiles porque eso nosotros regresamos
justo a lo que veíamos acá arriba y
decimos bueno justo aquí tengo ácidos
fuertes y bases fuertes y entonces se te
ocurre decir que si a éste ha sido
fuerte yo me pongo en la mitad de este
punto de equivalencia y calculo el punto
medio de equivalencia y justo aquí trazo
este valor para obtener el ph y así
obtengo el pk hay mi constante
equilibrio y no no hagas eso porque
recuerda que para algún ácido fuerte y
una base fuerte no tenemos constantes
equilibrio y la razón de eso recuerda es
porque estas se disocian por completo en
fin por ahora espero que ya tengas un
mejor entendimiento de qué es la
valoración de un ácido o de una base nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo